hey everyone I'm a be sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in celebration of one of
my favorite food holidays Easter I was
feeling spontaneous and a little
nostalgic and I thought it'd be fun to
go on the ultimate chocolate Easter egg
hunt adult style so we're gonna get in
the car we're gonna go on a road trip
and track down the best chocolate treats
the city has to offer let's get started
so first up we're heading north to the
rolling pin my Easter hunt would not be
complete without their quadruple
chocolate candy egg doughnut so excited
to make these ladies what are we doing
we're gonna take a yeast doughnut that
we fried and Isabelle's going to dip it
in a nice rich chocolate ganache and
then what we're gonna do is we're
actually going to take that little stick
doughnut poker yeah and we're gonna poke
a little hole right in the center don't
go all the way through
nope not all the way through so that
just allows us to put our chocolate
whipped cream in with ease
oh boy if it overflows don't worry Oh Oh
deal with it and Isabelle's gonna create
like a nice little basket like an Easter
basket and then we're gonna top it with
some mini Easter eggs oh those are my
favorite crunchy and sweet and then a
beefy one you can actually add some
chocolate cocoa nibs on top okay and
then the wow factor we're gonna use our
little shot and what we're going to do
is we're going to squeeze it up there
you got it
so what that is is chocolate ganache
with a little bit of whipped cream to
thin it out all right okay and then you
can just put that right into the
doughnut so you can squeeze it in for
later into your mouth right there yeah
love it thank you so much I cannot wait
a pleasure
all right where's next
so my next stop is a quick drive away
we're gonna go get my favorite cupcakes
at the pursuit of frosting these
chocolate hazelnut cupcakes are a must
on my Easter hunt list so severa how do
we make these movies well thanks for
coming by Abby so we've got chocolate
cupcakes I've hollowed out the center
and filled it with a chocolate hazelnut
filling as well as chocolate-covered
bright cereal just to give it some
texture you're gonna top it with some
chocolate hazelnut icing and then a B
I'll have you garnish it with some
chocolate shavings that I think look
like a nest and some candy eggs
I love that so we're putting a little
nest on top yeah for our little little
birds nest with my favorite kinds of
eggs of course I love that you add a
little bit of coffee to your chocolate
cupcakes cuz it really accentuates that
dark deep chocolate flavor and not
hazelnut chocolate combination is
irresistible in my book so I cannot wait
to bring these home with me thank you so
much thank you
alright let's go
so my next stop is just a quick zip
through the city we've got to check out
my friend David child's pop up his
chocolate treats are amazing tell me
about this egg it's impressive
thank you very much so these are my take
on you know classic Easter eggs everyone
has the usual small and large chocolate
Easter molds so I take mine a hand paint
and hand splatter them with edible cocoa
butters and I fill the molds with
tempered either milk white or dark
chocolates pop them out glue them
together and I paint the egg yolk in the
same way with edible cocoa butters and I
slowly drizzle the white chocolate on
top to get that effect of the egg white
and I plop the egg yolk right on top so
with an egg on an egg
these are significantly more impressive
than the chocolates I used to hunt for
when I was a kid I cannot wait to bring
these home thank you so much David it's
my pleasure so clearly our chocolate
hunt was a huge success
I found all my favorite chocolate treats
driving around the city for my local
purveyors I've got my chocolate cupcakes
my chocolate doughnuts I even found
these gorgeous hand-painted chocolate
eggs I hope this gives you all some
inspiration for planning your own
chocolate events you're driving around
the city well thanks so much for
watching for more great holiday ideas be
sure to subscribe to my channel and I'll
see you next time on Abbey's kitchen